[dramatic music]
Jesse, Teddy, congratulations.
You boys have made it
into the final round
of this competition.
Now when you showed up here, we
had you make fossil Damascus.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate something with a
little bit more recent history.
This.
[dramatic music]
This is a musketeer's rapier.
[sighing]
Oh, dear.
I told my wife before I
left, the one weapon I did
not want to build was a rapier.
Yeah.
Good luck, gentlemen.
We'll see you in four days.
Oh, we're screwed.
I'm speechless.
Good luck.
Holy crap.
It's day one.
And I get to build
the musketeer rapier.
So I'm using 5160.
It's tough.
It's springy.
Rapiers, since
they're so thin, they
are meant to flex a little bit.
So that's what we're going.
So today, my game
plan is to hopefully
get the blade roughed out.
That will allow
me to spend a lot
of time working on the
guard, making it elaborate.
But right now, I'm really
glad I have long arms.
I'd love to give
the judges something
that they want to stare at
just so much they want to use.
I've got the entire
blade shaped.
It's beveled.
I'm satisfied with where I'm at.
Day one, and I'm taking
on the musketeer rapier.
I'm going to go with bar
stock size of 80CrV2.
Super strong, should hold
up very well to the testing.
That's going to be the
hardest part because I don't
know what it has to survive.
Hey.
I'm about 40 and 1/2 inches
total length, which gives
me plenty of room for error.
I think I'm going to start
working on the fuller.
[rock music]
I can't complain about
that, my first ever fuller.
With all the factors involved
in this quench, the low roof
of the garage, the tall
quench tank, a ladder just
to reach above it--
I'm hoping that I can get
it right the first time.
[dramatic music]
God damn it.
Catastrophically, the sword
drops out of my hands.
I hear the tip hit the
bottom of the tank.
I pull the sword
out of the quench.
I see this huge bow.
I gotta get this thing
in my straightening jig.
I have no idea what's
going to come out.
I'm really scared.
I'm really nervous.
I'm thinking I'm going to
have to do this a second time.
So the sword's cooled off
in the straightening jig.
Let's see if I just
performed a miracle here.
It's time to open it up
and see what's inside.
Holy crap.
There's a slight warpage on
there, but nothing crazy that I
can't fix with a grinder.
She's hard.
I've never made a store before,
so I'm ecstatic right now.
The plan for the day is I
gotta get the blade and rough
ground and heat treated.
This thing is so freaking long.
And then it'll be onto all
the fittings and furnishings.
[rock music]
It's not biting.
It's not skating quite right.
I realize I have to requench,
I have to reharden this.
I just want to make sure that
when it gets to the judges,
it's going to survive
whatever they throw at it.
I haven't seen any warps.
So that is without a doubt hard.
It's still a little
bit beefy compared
to what I wanted in the long
run, but I'm satisfied with it.
For this handle, I'm going
to go with a nice hardwood
and offset that with a
different color micarta.
And then epoxy it together so I
can shape it off of the sword.
Yeah.
That came together pretty nice.
With the time I got left, I'm
going to started shaping all
these quillons,
and knuckle-bows,
and all that frou frou
stuff on the handles.
I'm really happy
with where I'm at.
The elements I have to get
finished are the knuckle-bow
with two sidebars and a pommel.
There's your knuckle-bow.
The fit and finish that
I'm going to put on it--
it's going to look rugged
but clean, pretty, and just a
overall well constructed piece.
$10,000 worthy, no doubt.
Dry fit up in place.
Looking good.
At the end of the
cross guard, I have
two quillons, dragon
fingers, claws that should
be clutching a gem or two.
They look dragonesque.
That's done.
It is a little bit heavy
for what I was aiming for,
but it has good balance.
So overall, I'm really happy
with how the sword turned out.
Today's going to be
all about fit and finish,
and completing this sword.
The blade itself,
I'm pretty much
happy with the geometry of it.
But I want to see if I can
remove some weight at the tip.
I want Doug to be swinging
that thing all over the place,
and having a good time with it.
[dramatic music]
Now that everything is
permanently affixed,
just got to clean it up,
sharpen up a little bit.
I can't wait to see the
judges test this thing.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
We're going to
take your rapiers,
and deliver some killing
slashes and thrusts
on this big carcass.
For these musketeer
swords, it's time
to find out if you're
all for one champion
or one for all the runner ups.
Jesse, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Let's cut some bacon.
All right.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
Dude.
He got a workout.
All right, Jesse.
This edge is sharp.
A rapier cut a pig in half?
That's very interesting.
For every slash, the edge lands
exactly where I want it to be.
OK.
Overall, sir, for
this test, it will kill.
Yes.
All right, ready, Teddy?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
[sighs]
All right, Teddy, your edge.
When you're slashing
with the razor's edge
that you have on your
blade, it slices easily
and deeply on this pig carcass.
Your weapon, sir, will kill.
Awesome.
Nice.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test--
a little thing I like to
call the wheel of pain.
Now a rapier it needs to be a
fast, light, flexible weapon.
We're going to see how
flexible yours are.
All right, Jesse, so
I've got your blade
strapped into our wheel
of pain right now.
Now I'm going to be flexing
it in both directions.
I'll be taking it all the
way to that far red peg,
holding it for
about three seconds,
and we'll see if
it comes back true.
And then we're going
the other direction.
All right?
Go nuts.
That ship sailed.
[dramatic music]
That was back to true, dude.
[applause]
Are you kidding me?
OK, Jesse.
First off, remarkable.
I mean, there's a lot of weight
in this blade, a lot of mass.
So to have it flex
the way it did,
and come back
virtually to true--
this blade is still straight
enough to fight with,
which is excellent.
Thank you.
Good job.
Teddy, you ready for this?
Let's do it.
[dramatic music]
Oh, freak.
[inaudible]
Holy crap.
So, Teddy, you can see
where it took the bends here
and here.
In the initial bend, it
actually bent this way.
And then we bent it back, and
then it went the other way.
So it leaves some question
about the heat treat--
you know, how even it
is through the blade.
You know, it's just--
I worry about that bend.
Teddy, unfortunately, a
less than perfect heat treat
has led to your rapier
taking a permanent bend.
Now this is going
to affect accuracy
when it comes to the use of the
weapon in our sharpness test.
And for that reason, this
is a catastrophic failure,
and you cannot continue
with this competition.
Come on forward, my friend.
Good job, brother.
I'm definitely not happy.
No one enjoys having anything
they build not work properly.
I've had a blast.
I've made a few good friends.
I've been able to take
time, and build something
I otherwise wouldn't
have built. So
that experience has been great.
Jesse, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for 10 grand.
Good job, brother.
[applause]
I'm on cloud nine.
This is probably the most fun
I've ever had doing hard labor.
I've proved to myself that
I'm capable to do a whole lot
more than I thought I could.
[dramatic music]